we haven't reviewed the reviewers in a
while do you want to review the
reviewers
uh let's try it again she was uh sorry i
don't know what her problem was i was
trying to keep it from falling no you
wear it don't touch it don't touch it
i'm making sure it doesn't fall don't i
don't don't touch it here we go it's
okay now okay
you're a crazy person all this is going
in you're so you're such an unhealthy
person i'm a rabbit oh my god okay you
have to keep that i am a rabbit so
people know no people need to know they
need to they didn't they need to know
that i'm a rabbit they do need something
else look at this look at what he's
doing oh my gosh look at what he's doing
just the guy hands i'm just a guy
elegant hand i'm just a guy no you're
not just a guy
no guy says i'm just a guy
i'm just a guy you're a rabbit yeah
okay let's do some let's uh oh my god
this is like i'm in class
the teacher doesn't see it and i see it
um i think there's no high-definition
cameras hey teacher look what he's doing
okay what you got there bingo all right
bingo we're gonna do what we gonna do
we're going to do review the reviewers
okay okay this is where i pull out some
reviews from the apple podcast review
section and we discuss them and we
discuss their merits i think it is good
to hear
how the people feel about what we're
doing in here are you drawing breasts no
i was drawing eyes but you go ahead i
thought it was a butt i have to say this
i've never noticed to be more easily
distracted yeah everyone's just like
whenever we start to do something let's
review the reviewers and then sona's
like did i just
taste tic tac you know and you're like
what literally as you said that a fiber
was floating through the air and i just
started [ __ ] okay let's start again
we're going to focus okay
i can't i all right all right it's all
going you're doing it you're doing it
though you know you're doing it
oh
i love that you do these things silently
to her and do forget that this is all on
video now but also none of these things
mean anything no you're like people
later
yeah all right let's go okay let's do
some review the review i love it i love
to hear
i'd love to hear what the people have to
think the way you say it like you didn't
just say it like three minutes
all this is going in anyway it doesn't
matter
do you not want to do this no i do
unbelievable what one more time you're
doing you're doing the phone thing okay
you got to stop you have to stop
yeah
it's
let's do some review the reviewers okay
love it i'd love to hear what the people
think okay as they think it there we go
okay this is from
megan
ik wood okay the title is bit in the
deliver room five stars
long time listener first time reviewer
i've been catching up on episodes from
sona and matt coming back from the
paternal leave as a mother of two it
occurred to me that conan doing bits in
the delivery room could be a benefit
working at team coco or another source
of revenue to hire conan out when i was
giving birth to my kids my husband and i
had no time to entertain the hospital
staff i was really bringing them down
bringing down the vibes with the whole
grunting and breathing business of labor
for a small fee conan could have
delightfully filled this vacuum
i can't think of a worse idea it's
terrible i mean horrible
sona as you can attest uh
what a
when you go to a hospital to give birth
to children the last thing you want
is some six foot four red flame-haired
clown yeah
doing bits
and i you know i have been in that
environment uh twice uh
for the birth of of my two children and
um
my bits were going nowhere i'll tell you
right now no one was interested in my
bits except
my wife certainly didn't want to hear
any of it and no one else was around
family friends didn't want to hear it we
did have a doctor
who looked after us
when uh
my wife was praying with my daughter
and i didn't even make an aggressive
joke i just i thought i was just you
know i didn't give it any thought and it
certainly didn't seem that funny to me
but um
this doctor
was talking to me because
my wife really wanted to try and have a
natural birth
and then he said uh okay
but if it does if it's difficult or if
you're in too much pain we could end up
or and the baby's not coming we could
give you some pitocin and i said what's
that he said pitocin is the drug that
really makes the baby come faster
and i said hey if my wife's in pain i
want you to serve her up a pitocin
omelette you know i just sort of like
said that and the guy was like
[Laughter]
put toasts in omelette
and you know when you say something and
you don't even love it that much i just
went hey if my wife needs it let's get
her a pitocin omelet anyway
and then
he kept
going out in the hall and be like this
guy
this guy and you know the worst is when
you have a joke that's not that great
yeah and someone then starts repeating
it for everyone he's like this kind of
like which guy that guy you know from
late night he said give her a picture
and they were like
i'm like i didn't say to repeat it i
didn't think it was i was just killing
time and then every time we saw him in
the months afterwards here comes hey i
got a chef working on your patos anomaly
oh no
um i scored a massive home run with this
guy i don't know why but i think he had
never heard someone make a joke using
pitocin
one of the main drugs that he used in
his work wow yeah so that was my
experience i promise you that it would
be awful
simply awful to have me in a delivery
room
while uh a woman is trying to give birth
to a baby yeah pass a human being
through the birth canal and i'm there
doing the string dance and going on
[Music]
a little bit i imagine if he was there
for your delivery no you know did i tell
the story about when he visited my dad
in the icu i can't remember if i did i
don't think so but it is it isn't about
your bits it was about you being conan
o'brien and you visited my dad in the
icu when he was getting heart surgery
and they all
abandoned their patients and they were
like conan o'brien is here and then they
started taking photos with him and it
was kind of crazy because i swear to god
i heard
people flatlining in other rooms like
and they i've never seen
they just rushed out yeah they abandoned
everything
people with like gloves oh oh my god a
guy came in to take a selfie with me
he's like holding a human heart
that he was supposed to put into a chest
cavity
and i'm like shouldn't you and he's like
out of it they don't go brain dead for
two minutes get in here
get in here let's get a let's get a shot
get a shot at three of us i remember uh
yeah visiting your dad in the hospital
which was very nice of you to do oh yeah
he went
with her family with everyone except
you're you're killing her dad your uncle
who said i could lose 10 pounds uh i'll
never forget that but anyway years ago
still brings it up still on a weekly who
says that i'm there visiting your father
bringing joy
bringing life when a man is facing his
mortality yes and this guy's like yeah
you could lose 10 pounds yes um
incredible so i say i shouldn't be
i should not be
in a maternity ward i should not be
anywhere where someone's giving birth
that's a mistake but
bring me in before someone's going to
have a surgery yeah
that is something i've had some
experience with i do very well with that
audience you're like a patch adams i'm
kind of a patch adams
yeah i'm a patch yeah i've got a little
rubber nose i keep in my lab coat and i
put it on uh no i i think that
that is the environment for me is um
because i think what happens is your dad
might have been worried
oh my god what if i don't make it
through this and then he talked to me
for 10 minutes and thought there are
upsides
there are upsides to leaving this earth
i don't have to hear this really white
guy hammer on
no but it was really nice
after he left he he became the guy in
the hospital who knew conan o'brien he
got the special surgery yeah he got the
special heart surgery
everyone else gets the shitty one yeah
they're like you know what we're gonna
do your heart surgery correctly
as there are special bonus treats
yeah all right well we know in my place
is that yeah and uh so to the listener
that's a bad idea